[Music]
after two gi joe films that failed to
set the world on fire
paramount is taking the origin story
approach with snake eyes
but with a new cast and fresh story
comes new details to account for
here are the biggest unanswered
questions from snake eyes gi joe origins
throughout most of the history of gi joe
the black bodysuit clad ninja commando
snake eyes is rarely unmasked
and doesn't speak and actor ray park
plays him this way in the rise of cobra
and retaliation after all giving snake
eyes a voice
and unmasking him in the films would
have gone against everything fans knew
about the character from his previous
appearances
in the comic book gi joe a real american
hero number 27
we learn in the snake eyes the origin
story that snake eyes face and vocal
cords were severely burnt in a
helicopter explosion while the commando
was serving in one of his first missions
with the joes
however in snake eyes gi joe origins we
learned that snake eyes suffered a
traumatic event in his childhood
growing up into a drifter who seeks
retribution for the tragedy
the reason for his new appearance is
simple we're meeting snake eyes earlier
in life and he doesn't actually put on
the helmet and face shield associated
with character
until the final scene no one cared who i
was till i put on the mask
naturally the film leaves the door open
for more snake eyes and
gi joe origins film adventures so only
time will tell whether henry golding's
iteration of the character will get to
the point where snake eyes doesn't
remove his mask and ceases to speak
that scenario appears to be unlikely for
paramount and hasbro in the short term
since it would make no sense for them to
conceal golden whose career has been on
the rise since his breakthrough in the
2018 hit romantic comedy drama crazy
rich asians
making a memorable first impression in
snake eyes is haruka abe
who plays the r chicago clan's head of
security a new character in the gi joe
franchise
the exciting thing for abba is akiko is
far from just a functional character in
snake eyes as director robert schwenke
gave the actor just as many scenes as
her co-stars
her character is so pivotal in fact that
she's getting a snake eyes gi joe
origins
action figure produced by hasbro that's
a true honor since
action figures are as pivotal to the
success of the franchise as
all its other forms of media on top of
all that akiko's storyline is primed to
continue akiko provides snake eyes with
his signature costume and mask and
joins him in his quest to get tommy back
after tommy swears off the arshikage
clan and becomes storm shadow
mauling akiko's potential involvement in
future gi joe installments abe is
certainly up for more akiko
telling looper in an exclusive interview
i think there's so much to be explored
about her background
and also her relationship her dynamic
with storm shadow and snake eyes so
yeah i can't wait to see where her
character will go
given that four major gi joe characters
have been recast for snake eyes
it appears the franchise is intent on
starting from scratch
since the first two gi joe films fell
short of box office blockbuster status
the franchise had to do some
major retooling and a reboot of the
movie series was the most sensible way
to do it
while future installments of gi joe
origins will depend on box office
performance and fan reception
the ending of snake eyes promises a
return of snake eyes
storm shadow the baroness and scarlet
that could come in the form of a snake
eyes 2 but
more likely if the studio is serious
about the backstory concept they could
return in a different
gi joe origins movie featuring another
joe or cobra character
as for the possibility of seeing any of
the actors from the rise of cobra or
retaliation turn up
it's pretty unlikely while the ending of
snake eyes promises more adventures with
the new cast
what those adventures will be and who
they will involve
remains a mystery based on the final act
and snake eyes one of the angles will
involve snake eyes and storm shadow and
to a larger extent the jose and cobra
since the baroness appears to have
recruited tommy into the ranks of the
organization
since gi joe origins is part of the
snake eyes film title
it's reasonable to think that more
origin movies could be on the way
whatever their current plans might be
paramount pictures isn't tipping its
hand in terms of the new direction of
the franchise just yet
however deadline reported in may 2021
that screenwriters joe shrapnel
and anna waterhouse who co-wrote the
2019 biographical thriller seaberg
starring kristen stewart
are writing their own movies set in the
gi joe universe meant to serve as a
sequel to and
build off of what was established in
snake eyes apart from any potential new
gi
joe films at least one other beloved
character from the franchise is getting
their own spin-off
in february 2021 deadline reported that
streaming giant amazon was developing a
standalone lady j series based on the
joe's famed undercover operative
making her debut in the gi joe animated
series in 1984
lady j was first played in live action
by adrian pilicki in gi joe retaliation
according to deadline the series will be
a standalone story centered around j
which will also connect to the larger gi
joe universe
could that mean that we could see
golding and his fellow snake eyes actors
appear in the lady j spin-off
while no actors or story timeline have
been revealed yet
it's possible check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one